my guest in focus ari fletcher former
white house press secretary and fox news
contributor now that was quite a wind-up
because not everybody can hear all the
questions that are being shouted
but we could clearly hear the response
from the president what was going on
there ari
well his communications team harris is
high-fiving each other they like the
fact that he tries to stay on message
that he didn't want to talk about
afghanistan even though he did but look
add it all
up joe biden is a trojan horse
with a script his opening everything he
talked about was a progressive
liberal spending spree that had nothing
to do with coven nothing to do with jobs
it's just a liberal wish list come true
and i can tell you this if donald duck
were the president you'd have the same
job numbers you have because kovitz been
defeated
that wasn't because of joe biden or his
jobs plan that's the inevitable result
of americans coming back to work
they're actually coming back to work
slower because of the excess
unemployment benefits that people are
getting
so add it all up the way he looked at
his notes the way he
had it on the card read from his po his
script
he is a trojan horse with a script
that's my summary
well here's the problem for the media in
that room and they can say what they
want to say about fox news
but those reporters were not all from
fox news they were all hungry for the
truth in that moment though
which might have been a refreshing
difference for some and certainly a
surprise for president biden because
we don't get his cards so when he starts
to look down and go from the car
we we don't have that and that's
probably an
excellent thing look i i want to ask you
about
really where he was though in the talk
about jobs i want to drill down
to where the nation really is he said
well we've created three million jobs
since january
that's an amazing great thing people
aren't
jumping to take them
yeah but the reason jobs are being
created is because covet is over
joe biden didn't end covet the vaccines
ended covent
and if any credit is to be given it was
as a result of the previous
administration the trump administration
that accelerated the production of these
vaccines
and joe biden is the lucky beneficiary
of that
um so that's why it's it's inevitable
it's natural that people go back to work
when the lockdowns end and when people
feel safer because
they're vaccinated he takes credit which
is what all politicians do they try to
say it's all the result of their plan
well and it never is it's never 100 that
there may be a teeny tiny element of
something
but that's what a typical politician
does that's what joe biden is doing
i am glad to see how reporters found
their own voice a little bit
and started to pepper him about
afghanistan and other topics
you know that's the usual cat and mouse
game between the white house press corps
and administrations they're still too
soft too friendly to joe biden
but at least they found their voice on
other questions today
yeah a start as a start as a start as
the start i suppose look real quickly
about the jobs one more time
if you pay people though continue to pay
those who
uh are waiting and it's only gonna last
till september i mean people are gonna
have to go
and find a job because no matter what
biden says that dole is not gonna be
there forever last quick thought on that
yeah buried in the numbers today is
what's called the labor force
participation rate it continues to be at
an excessively low level down the 61
percent level
typically it's up to the 63 64 level
the difference is massive what it means
is people aren't participating
in looking for jobs they're happy to
stay at home and they don't count as
part of being unemployed
because they're not looking for work why
aren't they looking for work
they don't need to in many cases it's
because they're getting their
excessive unemployment benefit check
which in some states can be forty
thousand dollars a year
much of it a portion of it tax-free to
stay at home and collect
unemployment that's the problem harris
all right ari let's get to this because
i mean that the white house is
multitasking today the white house
trying now to protect vice president
kamala harris
after those bombshell claims of an
abusive work environment
a top biden aide is calling it sabotage
a damaging politico report on the
infighting within her
office with this headline not a healthy
environment
kamala harris's office rife with dissent
quote there is dysfunction inside the
vp's office
aides and administration officials say
and it's
emanating from the top senior white
house
advisor cedric richmond told axios this
it's a whisper campaign designed to
sabotage her one person says something
long enough and it becomes an
urban legend it doesn't have to be
credible
okay so when you read the report before
this job
she was a g of california i mean she's
been she's been a senator she's had a
there were 22 people along the way
including those who are currently with
her
that that's not one person spreading a
gossip word
ari what do you make of it yeah well
first i guess whisper campaign is the
biden word for fake news
uh so you know chalk that up look
any time i read a story that has just
anonymous sources
my reaction is i'm just going to wait to
see if it comes true
you know maybe it's true there you go
sometimes it is sometimes it's not
but that was my standard for reading
stories about donald trump where i
always thought it was unfair that they
quote all these anonymous people
and i'm going to adhere to that standard
in the biden administration
now look is it true we don't know i mean
it is based on her history too that was
the case in her senate office that was
the case in her primary campaign
um but you know these little staff
things
it's about the person it's not about the
staff and whether they have a hard job
and they don't like it
is she doing a good job and this is
where joe
biden picked her so if they don't like
the job she's doing the fault lies with
joe biden
i do think she's not done a good job as
vice president
i think the way she's handled things it
really raises questions about whether
she's ready for this job whether she
is serious enough and she seems to just
wing it and you can't wing it either as
a senator
or as a vice president and certainly not
as a president
that's what she seems to be doing
i remember watching the zoom early in
joe biden's presidency and he had all
these employees on the wall and he says
if anybody
mistreats anybody he would personally
fire them
so if there is any truth to any of this
it will be interesting to see how
the president of the united states
handles it ari fleischer thank you
a blessed fourth to you thank you happy
july 4th